what if I told you that even the worst  neighborhood in America could be made  completely safe how do I know this  because it's happening right now in  every country in the world but this one  it is great to see American machines  helping to promote peace a bro so then  tell me why can't we use these machines  why is America so Robo phobic  we need to give Americans a product they  can love see you they can rally behind  we can't put a machine on the street  yeah machines they want a product the  conscience and something that knows it  feels like to be you mama yes my baby  too slow boy  we're gonna put a man inside the machine  time to wake him up more practical let's  go with black quality control PM 208 vs  Tin Man  we are going to make a lot of money he's  coming  don't play good-cop bad-cop bad-cop  Robocop these I'm doing what we did  thank you for your cooperation  you